Here's the starter code that we were given. We were already given the
declaration, for this variable, but we still have to initialize it. And down
here is, the loop, that we've had at the beginning of this lesson, that
arranges, all of the pictures. This time, all of the pictures inside matches,
so that they appear side by side. Our job is, to fill up, the ArrayList
matches. We need to initialize the variable, and here is the expression. We
called the new operator, because we want to have a new object and the type of
the object is ArrayList off the picture. The parenthesis here, again, just
means that we call the construct. Next, we loop through all of the pictures in
the original array list. For each one we decide whether it's a match. And so we
added to this ArrayList, that's all. As it happens with this set of pictures
there are two matches. Those of them are displayed here. Now you've seen quite
a few useful algorithms, but maybe you're getting a bit tired of our galleries
here. Go ahead and practice them with Sara in a different context.